welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Dawson a new spider-man Easter egg has
been spotted an early looks at Morbius
film that will apparently lean very
heavily into crossovers with spider-man
and spider-man characters and one thing
we noticed in that Morbius trailer is
that the spider-man they used is an old
version no not old virgin because you
know emo Peter Parker box but the Sam
Raimi era version of spider-man which is
odd because Morbius will also include a
cameo of Adrian Toomes vulture from the
MCU Tom Hollands spider-man homecoming
but with Marvel and Sony co-producing
the MCU spider-man they kind of have
joint custody of these folks far from
home ended in a post-credits scene with
Jay jonah Jameson played by JK Simmons
who played the character in the Raimi
films also far from home included in the
Easter Egg nod to bone saw McGraw the
wrestler played by Macho Man Randy
Savage in the rain the film and as a
character bone saw McGraw was original
in specific to the Raimi verse on top of
all this Marvel just hired Sam Raimi
himself to take over directing duties
for Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness road scott derrickson and as I
mentioned before Raimi's a great fit as
a guy known for successful Marvel films
and the horror genre but could there be
a deeper agenda behind the return of
Raimi some collusion between the MCU and
the Sony spider-verse I'm gonna break
down this conspiracy and the latest
spider-man cameo for what it could mean
for the future of the spider-verse
spoiler warning in case I'm right okay
so the latest clue was discovered in a
set photo from Los Angeles there was a
bus redressed as a New York MTA bus and
an ad reading where is spider-man find
out only in the Daily Bugle it
originally was believed that this could
be for venom two but it was later
confirmed to be part of the set for
Morbius so like the street art of
spider-man with the graffiti murderer
painted over it that we saw in the
Morbius trailer this could suggest a
connection to the ending apart from home
in which Peter Parker was outed and
falsely accused as a criminal but also
note that that Daily Bugle in this ad is
the Prince newspaper version of the
outlet that Jay jonah Jameson ran in the
Raimi's spider-man films the version
that Jameson runs and far from home is
an info war style conspiracy news
website so what's going on there well I
see three theories that explain what
this means theory one Morbius is setting
up the third at Tom Hollands spider-man
film to be a Peter Parker manhunt
perhaps the folks at Sony are trying to
keep their morbius and Venom movies wise
I connected to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe makes sense the promise of
interconnectivity to Feige springle
freakshow has been a huge success for
Sony so in addition to cameos by NC
villains like vulture we're also gonna
get these background nods to a fugitive
criminal spider-man to remind us of how
far from home and did fall in order to
make the hunt for Peter Parker the focus
for the next spider-man film in summer
2021 and who best to lead that hunt well
who's the mystery man with hunt in the
name that everyone's dying to drag into
the spotlight that's right hunter by
Diab yeah yeah Kraven the hunter
director Jon Watts mentioned Kraven the
hunter as his ideal villain for the next
film and I could definitely see media
figure Jake jonah Jameson bankrolling an
expert game hunter to capture this
public menace maybe a plot similar to
Cravens last hunt I explored this in
another recent video check it out
perhaps the bus ad suggests that Jay
jonah Jameson's fringe new site has
grown in popularity into a legit
subscription-based print operation then
again a web site transitioning into a
newspaper as many 50-year old poets or
winners who now have to fumble their way
through podcast advertisement talking
points will tell ya that is the opposite
direction that the media industry is
actually going oh speaking of which
thanks to our good friends at the ridge
for sponsoring this episode the ridge
makes everyday goods to a standard you
don't see every day they streamline your
life by turning the things you carry
like backpacks chargers and wallets into
tools for a better living their flagship
product is the ridge wallet it was
launched on Kickstarter in 2013 and now
sits in the front pockets of over 1/2
million men and women my wallet used to
be for like napkins covered in scrolled
spider-man conspiracy theories that
wasn't healthy but not anymore guys this
is their aluminum while it's in a raw
color now they do have other colors
including some very flashy Tiki designs
go check all those out but all of them
they're light they're strong and this
one has this cool industrial chic vibe
the ridge is a minimal front pocket
wallet that's designed to streamline
what you carry every day it has 30,000
five-star reviews and is a better way to
carry your cash and cards there's a
lifetime warranty if you love it three
returns if you don't it comes a titanium
carbon fiber aluminum and over a dozen
different styles and colors they also
have great backpacks and travel bags
with RFID blocking pockets and optional
device charging
get 10% off today with free worldwide
shipping and returns by going to Ridge
comm slash new rock stars
that's Ridgetown slash new rock stars
and used to code new rock stars find the
link in the video's description ok to
explain how this Daily Bugle newspaper
ad could connect to Jameson's Daily
Bugle website onto Theory number 2
Morbius is a prequel set before
spider-man homecoming designed to
establish how each of the members of
these sinister six will be behind bars
at the same time meet cube so let's
think back to when Tony Stark first
recruited Peter Parker in Captain
America's Civil War Peter had already
made a name for himself in the New York
area with enough of a reputation to
catch Tony Stark's eye perhaps during
this time in early 2016 j jonah Jameson
was running a print version of the Daily
Bugle running anti superhero headline
specifically targeting that reckless
dumbass who keeps game linked with
bodega bombings coinciding with all
these events could be Morbius may
remember him dr. Michael Morbius given
himself vampiric powers and a Hong Kong
Chabad and the way he gets to the
vampire Jim is by taking an anti Spidey
bus
perhaps over the years Jameson's
readership declines as this happened
with you know most print newspapers in
America until he hits a breaking point
the death of his son John Jameson Life
Foundation astronaut and the subsequent
cover-up this could inspire Jameson to
launch a conspiracy news website to seek
the truth and the events of Morbius
could leave that doctor in prison where
he meets also incarcerated Spidey
villains like the vulture like scorpion
like carnage folks were only two Rogi
blocks shy of a sinister six pyramid but
this theory doesn't explain why these
spider-man Clues are specifically the
rainy era spider-man once our final
theory does theory number three Morbius
is set in an alternate universe in the
last Spidey verse perhaps the reason
Raimi was hired to direct multiverse of
madness is because Marvel wanted his
oversight as they attempt to establish a
live-action
multiverse that can bridge over to Sony
spider-verse in the future and retcon
all past spider-man films like the
Andrew Garfield era and Sam Raimi's
Tobey Maguire spider-man as just
alternate realities within this shared
multiverse like maybe Morbius exists in
a reality in which spider-man is not Tom
Holland but maybe Maguire however
history still plays out similarly with
spy
man hated figure as he often is in the
comics and perhaps in this rainy verse
vulture is still played by Michael
Keaton but he doesn't have that mixed
gratitude toward Peter that he felt at
the end of homecoming is that Tom
Holland once saved his ass it looks like
by G's plan for multiverse of madness
could be to blow the doors wide open in
the MCU to all possible alternate
versions of Marvel heroes that we've
seen on-screen past and future in-house
Loki showrunner Mike Waldron will
rewrite the script for the Doctor
Strange sequel suggesting tie-ins with
the alternate timelines of that series
Ramey's direction could suggest that
among the alternate universe exploration
and multiverse madness could be a visit
to the Raimi verse a cameo by Tobey
Maguire and guys I don't think in that
Sony is well aware of the secret plan
and the Raimi Eric clues and Morbius are
evidence of this coordinated effort
between the studios to make their
back-to-back releases in may 20 21 and
July 20 21 and even more insanely
profitable to punch than endgame and far
from home were last year look I know
it's a lot to process I did introduce
this multiverse theory in last week's
episode of rogue theory and this
weekend's episode a big question will
explain everything there Marvel films
and comics have told us so far about how
the multiverse will work and for more of
my unfiltered thoughts about the behind
the scenes conspiracies by these
Hollywood power players Jonas on discord
that's where the real conversation is
happening here at new rock stars between
our staff and the geniuses of our inner
circle to join our discord become a
patron today at patreon.com slash new
rock stars do you think this spider-man
clue ties Morbius closer to the MCU or
sets it in its own rainy bursts comment
down below with your thoughts follow me
at EA boss following me rock stars in
social media and subscribe to new rock
stars here on YouTube for more of our
marble theories thanks for watching bye
[Music]